[Deadpool] ♪ You got to know when to hold 'em ♪
♪ Know when to fold 'em ♪
♪ Know when to walk away ♪
♪ Know when to run ♪
Deadpool.
Yeah that's right, I can't wait to join the gang. Can't wait to give Beast a nice little belly rub. It's gonna be great.
Yeah, I can't wait to move in. Who doesn't love rich mahogany?
[Deadpool] Seriously, it's called the X-MEN. I mean, there are women here, right? It's very sexist.
I know, right?
[Ajax] Put the little man down.
[Weasel] Thank you lesbian Commander.
[Ajax] We have everything we need now.
[Ajax] Thank you.
[Weasel] You don't have everything you need.
[Weasel] You're missing black hats, 1980's burglars.
Tell the rest of the trench coat mafia that they look better in a trench coat than the two of you.
He looks like that guy from Lord of the Rings if he had gotten cancer.
[Weasel] You're the size of Gollum. With worse taste in fashion.
[Deadpool] Sputnik! Let's fucking go!
Andale, andale! You big silver sex toy.
You tampon-chewing glistening communist fuck!
Let's go!
Dr. Phil can wait! You can watch the Matthew McConaughey Lincoln commercials later you communist fuck!
[Weasel] Watch your hair on the way out, sweetie.
It's low clearance.
Yeah, I didn't know Miley Cyrus joined The Cure, huh?
If you bring your son back, make sure he has ID.
The little one looked like Justin Bieber face-fucked Miley Cyrus's haircut.
You gonna leave me all alone here with ChristianMingle.com?
Leave me all alone here with Kevin Sorbo? You're gonna leave me here all alone with Nikki Sixx?
You're gonna leave me all alone here with Busta Rhymes? You're gonna leave me all alone here with Henry Winkler?
You're gonna leave me all alone here with
(sloth voice) "Hey you guys"
You're gonna leave me all alone here with Chris Angel Mindfreak?
You're gonna leave me all alone here with less-angry Rosie O'Donnell?
(Grunts)
Sorry, Gina.
[Angel Dust] (Laughing) Motherfucker.
Like a young Kirk Cameron.
You're not wearing any pants. Where'd you hide that?
[Wade] Uh, nowhere. They say, uh --
Oh, I wouldn't do that.
(Laughs)
[Wade] Happy Lime Disease Awareness Day.
[Director] Remember to have fun with it!
[Vanessa] (Laughs) Okay!
[Wade] Thank you.
[Wade] Ah! Fuck, you alright?
[Wade] Happy Alanis Morissette Day.
[Weasel] What are you gonna say to her?
[Wade] God damn it!
[Weasel] Nah, you should lead with a joke. You know, something tasteful, but it also alludes to her pussy.
You might wanna leave the room,
because I bet it feels huge in this hand.
Or stay!
Let's go next-level with this shit.
Oh!
Easy, easy... come on, cut (laughs)
Surprise surprise, happy Friday. So just the Deadpool bloopers, outtakes,
banned material, jokes that they had to pull out of the film. I'll do a new round of the Logan Blu-Ray giveaway,
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber.
Leave a comment on this video.
Hands down, probably my favorite outtake from this is her licking that Star Pop. Where'd you hide that?
Oh you know, no where. Not totally up my butt.
Just takes a big, ol' lick of it.
Oh jeez, that's foul.
If you guys didn't know, she is coming back for the sequel.
Most of the characters that didn't die off are coming back and obviously we have Josh Brolin coming on as Cable.
The biggest thing about that too -- he started to tease his workouts, like he's gotta get those huge Cable guns --
but he had to sign a five-picture deal
and I think that's mostly working out because Thanos won't be quite as big a deal after both of these upcoming Avengers films.
But we can talk about that when we get there. Let me know: which one of these
outtakes from this is your favorite? And this is Ryan Reynolds reacting to the movie getting banned in China:
[Reynolds] In a world divided by fear, one man must stand alone:
Deadpool. Rated fuck you, you'll never see this.
(Miller laughs)
No, honestly, it's easy for me to wear that as a badge of honor, like, "we got banned in China"
I hate that. I wish -- I love China and I would love the people of China to see Deadpool.
Obviously, they're really careful about the movies they let in. You can't have certain supernatural elements,
you can't do really crazy violent stuff like this... the list of things that they censor is crazy.
So let me know if you live in a part of the world that censors movies from the United States this heavily,
that won't let movies in if they're this graphic -- or I should say, this awesome. Whole bunch of comic book stuff posting tomorrow,
I have some new Justice League. They talked a little bit about the new scenes that Joss Whedon has been working on for the past
couple of months. They'll be shooting pretty soon.
So while you wait for that to post, you can click here for brand new Spider-Man: Homecoming
footage and you can click here to rewatch the
Deadpool 2 teaser trailer.
Thank you so much for watching. Let's high-five, I'll see you guys tonight.